ibrahim says he'll never forget the day
a car bomb nearly killed him
he says his shattered legs were gushing
blood
he's a mechanic in somalia's capital
mogadishu you know
it was in the morning when a client
brought me his car for repairing as soon
as i started working on it the car blew
up because it had a bomb attached and i
didn't know about it
he's here in the street right outside of
tosh's home that him and other mechanics
work on tuk-tuks cars and bikes and it's
right here that the bomb went off
he would have joined the other hundreds
of somalis who died in armed conflict
every year if it wasn't for one man
dr ahmed abdul qadeer mohammed says he
was tired of seeing people bleed to
death so he set up somalia's only public
blood bank funded by private donors
this is what inspired him five years ago
about 600 people were killed when two
truck bombs exploded in mogadishu it was
the worst attack in somalia's history
investigators blamed the armed group
al-shabab many of those killed bled to
death from their injuries
dr ahmed decided to do something about
it
it feels like the country is in an
emergency all the time with many
explosions and accidents there is always
a need for blood this center supplies
blood to many hospitals in the city to
save the lives of wounded people mothers
in childbirth and others
atosh is one of the many people who've
been saved with the blood that dr ahmed
collects
he and his team deliver it to hospitals
where it's needed
he says more people die of blood loss
than from the bullets that hit them and
the un says about 5 000 women die in
childbirth in somalia every year
many of whom could be saved by blood
transfusions
moalim
is another one of the blood recipients
he says a doctor misdiagnosed him with
tuberculosis and gave him strong drugs
that destroyed his kidneys he now
depends on kidney dialysis with donated
blood
it's a good thing for the community
without him so many people would be
dying because of lack of blood like me
if i did not get blood from him it would
be hard for me to stay alive
dr ahmed says finding donors is hard he
says he's met many people who believe
they'll die if they donate he speaks on
tv and radio every week to educate and
encourage people
the bank stores enough blood to treat
just a few hundred patients it's a start
but he says he has a long way to go to
meet somalia's needs
malcolm webb al jazeera mogadishu
somalia